when the people who get everything wrong
or ignore the stories then reality just
kind of keeps on coming right so they
miss all of the stuff when it happens
and then reality keeps coming and then
they flip right in front of your eyes
and you're like oh they're not so bad
but you must remember that they are here
is a video of Jake Tapper again he's a
he's a Democrat that's okay Jake you
should just say it he's a Democrat and
he's shocked that we're not having a
national conversation about the Damage
Done to kids from closing schools but
I'm going to just give you the lead
right now uh we've all been having that
conversation what he means is he's not
having the conversation videotape I have
to say I'm surprised that there hasn't
been
a national
conversation about the Damage Done to
kids because of these school closures
and the virtual learning and everything
because I mean I'm not saying there
should be a national do-over but we
can't just pretend that fifth graders
who are now seventh graders
that that didn't happen you know like I
feel like there should be and not not
with a Blame Game look it happened
people did it it was criticized the
school closures the virtual learning Etc
but here we are
um
there needs to be like like a bipartisan
movement you know Jake is shocked Jake
is shocked that there wasn't a national
conversation about this well Jake we
were all talking about it everyone
online that is doing your job better
than you with way less resources uh was
doing this we were all talking about how
kids should be at school how masks don't
work how forcing Jabs doesn't work how
this is going to cause all of these
problems that we now know whether it's
delayed speech in young children or
myocarditis in you know T young male
teenagers like we were all talking about
it where were you so he's saying well we
don't want to play the blame game but
dude mirror get one like come on now
come on now but what's interesting is so
now it's finally bubbling forward and
there he is I mean he has Jeb Bush on
like talk about completely irrelevant
you have a completely irrelevant guest
who has no clout within either political
party to come on and talk about how you
didn't do your job properly something
like that but people are seeing it
people really are seeing it